Kjell ching has made himself at home
today is the first day he gets to meet
the public hundreds of visitors at the
Berlin Zoo couldn't wait to take a look
at him and his female companion Hmong
Mong the newcomers from China while none
Hmong had a little trouble getting used
to the new environment the jail Ching
didn't let the stress get to him their
spacious home was constructed
specifically to meet the needs of the
endangered species says the director of
the Berlin Zoo and rescue team we meet
their needs first of all because the
animals haven't been captured in the
wild they are not used to keep a
distance to humans in fact they were
raised by animal keepers in China alcove
oxen we are in jail Chang's backyard
Xiao Qing is the male panda who just
arrived here from China and the pandas
don't really get to meet a Hmong Mong
the female and Xiao Qing apart from
mating season so the zoo does everything
to keep the panas entertained while
they're by themselves as you can see
behind me they they created a little
playground with platforms which we will
hopefully soon as see Xiao Qing playing
on as soon as he gets gets used to this
outside enclosure but not only that to
make the pandas feel at home landscapers
also try to recreate the Chinese
landscape you see a beautiful waterfall
going down here flowing down here and if
you look closely you can see smoke
coming out which is supposed to look
like fog and these details don't mean a
lot to most visitors face to face with
the giant pandas many are simply
fascinated I just want to give them a
hug they are so sweet and lovely and
innocent sure it's great to have them
but I don't think my kids and I will go
look at them today they keep munching on
these things I thought it was so cute we
will wait for a couple of weeks until
things have calmed down then we'll go
have a look the pandas are likely to
boost visitor numbers and Lea's
Collegium is well aware of the symbolic
value of his pandas but he's not
interested in panamania he wants
visitors to think about what they are
seeing
isn't kind of pops they aren't pop stars
but animals with the meaningful message
regarding important problems in nature
hype doesn't help with these issues I
would like to be able to calm the
public's fascination I suggest that
every visitor asks themselves if what
they do every day serves nature best -
are we eating time for dinner - effort
lately not just a major attraction but a
symbol of nature
Berlin's cute little pandas may be young
but they've already taken on a big
responsibility